premiers échanges directs entre l'iran
et l'arabie saoudite
du jamais vu depuis cinq ans et la
rupture des relations diplomatiques
entre téhéran et ryad
une première rencontre dans le but de
ressouder les liens auraient lieu à
bagdad le 9 avril dernier
dans une longue interview diffusée ce
mardi par plusieurs chaînes saoudienne
le prince héritier mohammed bin salman
s'est montré particulièrement conciliant
avec le grand rival iranien l'iran est
un pays voisin et tout ce que nous
souhaitons c'est d'abord une bonne
relation avec l'iran
nous ne voulons pas de difficultés pour
l'iran au contraire nous voulons une
croissance de l'iran et conduire la
région et le monde vers la prospérité
un changement de ton remarquer du côté
iranien
mais téhéran s'est contenté de saluer la
bonne tenue d'un dialogue avec l'arabie
saoudite si un éventuel rapprochement
des deux grands rivaux régionaux restent
plausibles le ton apaisé adoptée à
propos de la guerre au yémen a
particulièrement surpris les médias de
la région
l'entretien n'a guère apporté de
surprise sur le sujet économique
là où il a surpris c'est sur les sujets
de politique étrangère et notamment les
relations avec l'iran et le dossier
yéménite avec un ton calme coïncidence
ou non ces discussions interviennent
alors que le président américain joe
biden envisage de faire revenir les
états unis dans l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
une troisième session de négociations
s'est ouvert ce mardi à vienne pour
permettre ce retour